بايدن ذاهب إلى المملكة العربية السعودية ، ونحن
نتفهم جميعًا سبب رغبته في ضخ
المزيد من النفط ، ولكن سيُطلب من السعوديين
شيئًا
صعبًا للغاية في إيران ، وأتصور
أن ريتشارد يمكن
للولايات المتحدة أن تجد طريقة
للتعامل مع القضية النووية الإيرانية
في  الطريقة التي جربها بايدن
وإدارة أوباما والتي كانت
نوعًا من
الصفقة واسترضاء المملكة العربية السعودية أو أن هذين
الهدفين المتناقضين فقط متناقضان في
النهاية لأنه
حتى لو تمكنا من العودة
إلى الاتفاقية مع الإيرانيين ، فسيتم
شراؤها ببساطة  قليلًا من الوقت على
الجانب النووي ، لن يشتري لك
أي شيء على الجانب الصاروخي ، ولن
يقدر أي شيء على
جانب زعزعة الاستقرار الإقليمي الذي قال ، أعتقد
أن احتمالات العودة إليه
طويلة ، لذا أعتقد أن هذا يصبح جزءًا  من
المحور الجديد في الشرق الأوسط
مجاني ولدينا جيل حيث كان جزء كبير من
الشرق الأوسط على طول
الانقسام الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني ، ثم على طول
الانقسام العراقي ، أصبح الآن على طول
الانقسام الإيراني وبغض النظر عمن هو
رئيس وزراء إسرائيل بما في ذلك بيبي
نتنياهو ، هناك إجماع على
شيء واحد هو الخط المتشدد تجاه إيران ، لذلك
أعتقد أن إسرائيل والمملكة العربية السعودية
تشاركان ذلك والسؤال الحقيقي هو هل تريد إدارة بايدن
أن تتحول إلى
آسيا؟  من الواضح أنه منخرط بشدة
في أوروبا حيث كنا نناقش للتو
ما إذا كانت لديها الرغبة
والنطاق الترددي لاتخاذ موقف صارم
تجاه إيران ، فقد يكون هذا
اختبار السياسة الخارجية الكبير لهذه
الإدارة قبل أن يتم كل شيء آخر